Speaker 1: All right. This is really a good
one. Even Fox News host Larry Kudlow is now
saying to Republicans, it really doesn't seem
like you have evidence that Joe Biden committed
any crimes. The example we're going to look at is
from yesterday. This is Larry Kudlow talking to
Republican Senator Ron Johnson. Remember that
the context here is that they supposedly have
a whistleblower or informant or an informant on a
whistleblower with evidence of Biden crimes. They
or he or she is missing. They quite literally,
they said we don't know where the person is and
it's all just a comedy of errors. And now even
on Fox News, Larry Kudlow is like, you know,
you don't really seem to have the evidence. And
Ron Johnson goes with a classic conspiracy line,
which is the lack of evidence is the evidence,
because it proves that the criminality has been
covered up. This is a classic among conspiracy
theorists. Listen to this, folks. This is just
embarrassing for these people, Not.
Speaker 2: Biden himself as vice
president and maybe as president has not
yet been clearly fingered. That's all.
Speaker 1: He is. That's actually
that's correct. They I mean,
they're trying they're pointing. But there has
not been a successful fingering of Joe Biden that
Kudlow is willing to admit it. Good for him.
Speaker 2: And may be as president has not
yet been clearly fingered. Right. The so-called
bribery allegations pay for play by a national
affecting some kind of policies. Hasn't that
last step or two? Senator Johnson. We have really
fingered him, and I don't know how important this
informant is. Informant? I don't know if there's
anybody else that could do it, but it seems to
me that's going to leave a very big missing link.
Speaker 1: Yes. Called evidence.
Speaker 2: Well, we need all the bank records.
I know James Coleman hasn't been able to get all
the bank records, but let's face it, criminals
hide their criminal activity. They don't make it
easy for people to uncover their wrongdoing. And
so these investigations are painstaking. You've
got to, you know, pick out one piece of evidence
and try and follow that thread to the next
piece. And again, when you've got a complicit,
corrupt media that won't report, oh, this shows
that in terms of all the evidence, we already
do know of the corruption of the Biden family.
Right. We sure like this guy president. They're
still covering up for him. It's a real issue.
Speaker 1: That's a sitting senator casually
referring to the president of the United States
as a criminal absent any evidence whatsoever. And
listen to what he said. The lack of evidence
is the evidence because criminals cover up
their crimes and it's the media's fault. This is
classic conspiracy theory, circular reasoning,
where the conclusion is assumed to be true.
And if there's evidence that contradicts it,
it's dismissed as part of the cover up. If
there's a lack of evidence that contradicts it,
it's dismissed as part of the cover
up example. Q And on right, none of
the Q and on predictions have come true that
would seem to suggest. Q and on isn't credible.
Debunks the conspiracy theory, right? Wrong. Q And
unbelievers believe that the media is simply not
reporting that Q's predictions have come true, and
therefore. Q is right because the media is lying
by not reporting how Q's predictions have come
true. Oh, well, hard to argue with that, right,
because it's an indie feasible statement. So how
do you deal with this? I don't know. How do we
prevent people from falling into this this trap?
There's not a simple answer. Conspiracy theories
are extraordinarily complex, and we've had so many
interviews about that. There's a psychological
component. Social, cultural. There's a political
dimension. And there isn't a one size fits all
kind of solution to disabuse people of conspiracy
theories, particularly lack of evidence. Is part
of the evidence. So it's like a broken record. We
need to educate people and critical thinking. How
to evaluate a source of information. Understand
whether a statement being made is a statement of
fact or a statement of opinion. What is evidence
and what is speculation? What is accepted science
and what is pseudoscience? All of that. We need to
engage with the conspiracy theorists respectfully
and empathetically, which I understand is
really tough to do, because many of their
ideas are certainly worthy of being mocked. And
then third one, we need to create an environment
where abandoning these conspiracy theories is
welcomed rather than I told you, you were an
idiot. We need to make the environment where you
abandon the conspiracy theory a welcoming one,
where it's like, it's so great that you came
to this conclusion. I think this is great. And,
you know, honestly, having done this, you'll
probably be less likely to fall for stuff like
this in the future, that sort of thing. But it
is not an easy task. And when even on Fox News,
they are getting to you seem to kind
of be lacking evidence here, you know,
that there is absolutely nothing there. And
that is abundantly clear at this point in time.